good morning uh within the last hour
Manchester Airport has temporarily
closed two of its runways due to heavy
snowfall the icy conditions are set to
continue into next week with
temperatures set to drop as low as minus
15 in Scotland and snow is forecast for
London and also the southeast
now the Met Office is warning freezing
fog sleet and snow could bring travel
disruption to parts of the UK during the
coming days a yellow weather warning for
snow and ice covering large areas of the
country over the coming days
I will joining me now is Sky's uh Fraser
Maude who's in York for us this morning
uh looks Jolly cold where you are Fraser
and we need to brace ourselves for more
to come
it certainly seems that way Anna yes it
is about zero minus one here in York at
the moment and just in the last few
minutes a few tiny little snowflakes
have just started to fall much more uh
snow overnight over in Manchester though
unfortunately and both runways at
Manchester Airport have had to be
temporarily closed we've received news
in the last hour from Manchester World
Port saying that due to heavy snowfall
we have temporarily closed both runways
health and safety will always be our top
priority in operations we'll resume at
the earliest opportunity it says that
passengers are advised to contact the
airlines their Airlines for the most
up-to-date information now we understand
that what's happening at the moment is
that snow and slush is being cleared off
the runways outbound flights at the
moment seem to be on hold inbound
flights are being diverted to other
airports mainly Birmingham East Midlands
or to London airports so clearly
disruption already to Flight Services in
and out of Manchester Airport not clear
how long it's going to take for them to
clear the those runways get them back
into a serviceable state or not but the
travel advice remains at this time of
year and when weather conditions are as
cold as this to check before you travel
particularly with the public truck with
public transport if you're traveling by
yourself if you are traveling by car
make sure that you've got a flask of hot
water with your hot drink with you that
you've got blankets that you've got a
shovel even to get you out of a more
perilous situations because we are going
to get a lot more snow there are
warnings in place for Scotland for the
southeast as well and then overnight and
in tomorrow into tomorrow we're seeing
more Frost warnings for the Southwest
for Northern Ireland and for parts of
Wales as well so we really do need to
brace ourselves over this weekend people
need to keep warm the advice is to try
and make sure that you look after any uh
particularly vulnerable people in you
know friends family neighbors and so on
particularly the elderly make sure that
they're in one room at least that's
heated to 18 degrees C and that they
have access to hot food and hot drinks
so it's a case of keeping an eye out for
each other keeping an eye out on the
travel conditions and for people who are
hoping to travel from Manchester Airport
keep an eye on their Twitter feed on
their social media feeds so get in touch
with the airlines that they do to fly
with and double check to make sure that
those flights are going to be
operational later today the situation
could get worse over the weekend we're
expecting colder weather tomorrow and
there's a possibility of severe travel
disruption on Monday morning as we hit
the rush hour then because there are
snow warnings in place for parts of
London and the southeast so it's not
unusual to get this sort of weather at
this time of year it feels a lot colder
because of the mild Autumn that we've
been having but temperatures here in
York as I say at the moment around about
zero we're expecting them to drop in
more rural parts more remote parts of
the country maybe down as far as -10
tonight or tomorrow all right and check
before you travel um Fraser thank you
very much indeed go and get yourself a
hot chocolate